the biden administration bans horse
patrols at the border the democrats
struggle to put together their giant
budget and aoc cries about jews
defending themselves i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn you have a right to privacy
defend your rights at expressvpn.com
ben will get to all the news in just one
moment first here is your reminder that
you are just paying a lot of money for
your cell phone like for no reason at
all because you're using one of the big
cell phone providers right you want the
great coverage and you figure you got to
get it through one of the big providers
only one thing you don't stop paying for
verizon a t and t-mobile's social
initiative stop paying for their
thousands of retail stores across the
country that you never go into stop
paying for the added perks you never use
pure talk isn't going to charge you for
any of that garbage instead they give
you killer 5g coverage on the same 5g
network has one of the big guys for
about half the cost the average family
is saving over 800 a year so what
exactly is your excuse i made the switch
you can too keep your number keep your
phone or get huge discounts on the
latest iphones and androids you can get
unlimited talk text and six gigs of data
for just 30 bucks a month and listen if
you still want unlimited data you can
get it and still save a fortune head on
over to puretalk.com shop for the plan
that's right for you they have a 30-day
risk-free guarantee so you literally
have nothing to lose go to puretalk.com
enter promo code shapiro you will say 50
off your very first month that is
puretalk.com promo code shapiro puretalk
is simply smarter wireless save yourself
a bundle by switching over puretalk.com
promo code shapiro alrighty so the biden
administration is faced with this crisis
on the border they're apparently trying
to empty this thing out as fast as
possible it's like gavin newsom emptying
out all the freeway underpasses right
before the recall election and all the
homeless people are back by the way i'm
in california right now and i just went
and checked under the freeway
underpasses they are all back because
gavin newsom was not in fact recalled so
joe biden is doing the same thing at the
southern border apparently a lot of the
southern border area under this del rio
bridge was cleared but there's still
about five thousand people who
apparently are staying there according
to politico a report from renuka rayasam
over at politico saying
that things are winding down there's
still 5000 people in the camp that's
much lower than the 15 000 person peak
mexico has cracked down on the akuna
side so it'll be difficult for more
people to show up i guess maybe by the
beginning of next week there will be
very few people left if any but it's
still a zoo because there are so many
people it's hard for volunteers to keep
up he said i met some asylum seekers at
the airport they said they would they
would be sleeping on the bench i gave
them the number to the haitian bridge
alliance to see if they could help them
find accommodations they said there's
nothing in a hundred mile radius they
have the money to buy a hotel room but
no options so they've been sleeping on
the streets so things are obviously
going really really well over at the
southern border and the
the biden administration has come up
with a solution they're going to blame
it on the horses so you remember over
the past several days there's been this
myth that border patrol was going around
and whipping haitian migrants like
whipping them like taking whips and
hitting them with the whips like slave
patrols or something well as it turned
out those are called horse reigns and
you use them when you are riding a horse
as i said yesterday i not i may not be
much of a cowboy but i've seen enough
cowboy movies to know what it looks like
when you hit a horse on the flanks with
the reins
of the of the horse
apparently the biden administration
however has fallen full skill into the
narrative that the border patrol here
are the bad guys and so they've decided
there will be no more horse patrols
they're actually spending
one of the
parts of the border patrol that actually
polices the border in the middle of a
border crisis
in order to
satiate the idiotic media who don't know
how horses work
nick miroff over at the washington post
reports
the biden administration has now
directed u.s border officials to suspend
patrols by agents on horseback in the
del rio texas migrant camp
saki said homeland security secretary
alejandro marcus told civil rights
leaders thursday morning we would no
longer be using horses in del rio here
was saki announcing just this
we feel those images are horrible and
horrific there is an investigation the
president certainly supports overseen by
this the department of homeland security
which he has conveyed will will happen
quickly i can also convey to you that
the secretary also conveyed to civil
rights leaders earlier this morning that
we would no longer be using horses in
del rio so that is something a policy
change that has been made in response
they shoot horses don't they just blame
the horses so here you have a bunch of
people trying to hoof it across the
border and the biden administration is
unable to reign it in so finally biden
just said nay
well the main point is all this is just
horse
because there is no rationale for it
whatsoever okay they literally took the
people who are police what are they
gonna put them on segways out there
like this is rough terrain in the middle
of a river so you're gonna have paul
blart border patrol agent
wandering around there out on his segway
trying to stop people from crossing the
border illegally
this is their solution because of course
it is never about actually solving the
problem it is just about the political
spin of the moment this administration
has no long-term vision other than just
spending oodles of money and making lots
of people dependent they have no
long-term strategic vision everything is
just news cycle of the moment
and honestly some of this is due to
social media and just the nature of
things which is that if you just wait
long enough it will get out of the news
right we still have thousands of green
card holders stuck behind enemy lines
thanks to the taliban and the biden
administration and no one cares anymore
we just forgot about them they don't
matter okay that it's not even the end
of september yet okay we only left like
a little over three weeks ago and
everyone just forgot about the tens of
thousands of siv holders and the
thousands of green card holders in
afghanistan and the taliban are taking
all over and their leadership is saying
we're chopping off hands again it's you
know we're back
they're back and better than ever the
boys are back and they're ready to chop
off some hands and the biden
administration is like well the news
cycle moved on and you know what that's
what that was the plan their plan is
always can we delay long enough for
people to forget about what's going on
and move on to the next short-lived news
cycle that's always what this is and so
every answer from gensake is not
directed it actually providing
information it's all directed at kind of
these snarky little comebacks that don't
make any sense if you think about them
for 10 seconds so for example peter
ducey is asking about the fact that
there are a bunch of people who are
being deported into the not deported
they are being shipped into the interior
of the united states there have been
reports now from the associated press
from nbc news that people are literally
just being released into the interior of
the united states and all women have to
do to be released is claim that they are
pregnant which means that the border is
not actually under control so peter
ducey asks sake about this and listen to
her answer and the entire media's like
slay queen slay
queen because all that matters is the
headline of the moment
this is what by by the way the media
couldn't stand it when it was trump and
it was trump trump figured that too he
figured okay i'll just do whatever i do
and five minutes later the news cycle
will move on
but biden is taking advantage of the
exact same effect and because the media
are a bunch of squirrels and they just
want to run after the next nut they see
they will
by this time next week no one will be
talking about the border crisis anymore
we'll be on to whatever the next thing
is saki knows that so she can do these
slay queen idiotic little lines that
make no sense here we go
are you suggesting you don't believe
when women say they're pregnant is that
a big issue we think at the border i am
not in charge of keeping the border
secured
you guys are pregnant women are posing a
big threat to the border
to the border communities is that a big
issue
you tell me i'm not aware of pregnant
women being a big issue of concern to
people at the border that's not even
what ducey was talking about what ducey
was saying is you obviously don't have
control of the border you're letting
people in you're not testing people for
covet you're not testing people who
claim they're pregnant so that they can
just come into the country so why
exactly would we believe that you have
any significant standards for how the
border is being policed and instead
zaki's like what do you have against
pregnant women you know like pregnant
women are you saying these women are
lying about their pregnancy don't you
know believe all women like what in the
hell are you talking about that's not
even the question
like if you if you ask her a question
that doesn't fit into the neat little
intersectional box just rams it into the
intersectional box and the entire media
cheers like a bunch of crazy people
meanwhile he got this administration
ripping its own haiti envoy so there's a
special envoy to haiti the special envoy
to haiti quit because they looked at the
buy administration
policies and they said this is idiotic
either you gotta let people in or you
gotta not let people in but you can't do
this sort of half-assed routine so saki
just starts ripping her own haiti envoy
imagine if the special envoy to haiti
under donald trump had quit and then
trump got an admit that guy's an idiot
he doesn't know anything he's the worst
it'd be like look at him disrespecting
members of his own administration look
at that what violation of norms here's
jen saki just doing this and everybody
going okay
special envoy foot had ample opportunity
to raise concerns about migration during
his tenure he never once did so now that
wasn't his purview his purview was of
course being the special envoy on the
ground his positions were and his views
were put forward they were valued they
were heard different policy decisions
were made in some circumstances oh well
i guess that then then it's okay like
there's no big deal anymore okay in just
a second we'll get to the fact that
democrats on the border who actually
have to live in these areas are still
pretty ticked about all of this and it
has not in fact been solved first if
you've been having trouble falling
asleep or staying asleep one of the best
things you can do is start getting
enough magnesium you probably haven't
thought about that don't run to the
store and just buy the first magnesium
supplement you find most magnesium
supplements use only the two cheapest
synthetic forms and since they're not
full spectrum they're not going to fix
that magnesium deficiency or help you
sleep better there are actually seven
unique forms of magnesium you have to
get all of them if you want to
experience the calm sleep enhancing
effects of magnesium which is why i
recommend magnesium breakthrough by
bio-optimizers you can simply take two
capsules before you go to bed and you
will be amazed at how much better you
sleep and how much more rested you feel
when you wake up
for an exclusive offer for my listeners
head on over to
www.magbreakthrough.com shapiro use code
shapiro10 to save 10 when you try
magnesium breakthrough and one more
thing for a limited time buy optimizers
is also giving away free bottles with
their best-selling products p-3-m and
mass exams with select purchases so head
on over to www.magbreakthrough.com
shapiro now get your exclusive 10
discount plus the chance to get more
than 50 bucks worth of supplements for
free go check them out
magbreakthrough.com
shapiro use code shapiro 10 and save 10
when you try magnesium breakthrough okay
so
even democrats are looking at the biden
administration and saying this is
ridiculous
democratic representative frederick
wilson who until now is most famous for
wearing crazy hats she says haitian
immigrants are showing up because they
hear that the border is open
there are cottage industries that have
grown
around the border
where we have
people or smugglers who are passing
information to haitian
refugees haitian deport haitian uh
immigrants that come
the border is open so they have saved
their money they have paid
yeah that is frederico wilson and
democrat from florida democratic
representative henry cuellar is saying
the same thing he's saying listen
remember that time when they sent kamala
harris down here and she was supposed to
solve everything it turns out kamala
harris has never been able to solve a
single thing
to point out these tens of thousands of
haitian migrants that are that we know
about uh in latin america possibly
making their way north hoping to get to
the border between mexico and the u.s um
in the wake of vice president harris's
trip to latin america what do you think
the impact has been has anything changed
without due respect no
um no
without due respect
the harsh words there from henry cuellar
of course nothing has changed because
the bite administration has no actual
policy they just have what can we do at
this moment to get to just get beyond
what exactly is the issue whatever we
can do at this moment to be on the issue
okay so what is the actual long-term
vision here as i've said there's no
actual strategy here there is a
long-term vision the long-term vision is
what if we just tax the living hell out
of everything that moves tax it until it
dies and then we use the roadkill what
if we just do that we'll just tax
everything that moves and we'll spend
ungodly amounts of money
effectively nationalizing half of
american industries through regulation
right either overtly nationalizing
industries or by expanding things like
medicaid and medicare or
actively
using regulation to the extent that
effectively the government has prevented
you from
all of your property rights being
exercised right the right to property is
not merely the right to own anything it
is the right to dispose of that thing is
the right to use the thing if the
government gets rid of many of the
sticks in the bundle of property rights
effectively it is no longer your full
property this is part of joe biden's
actual proposal right you you will not
be in control of your own economic
freedom you will not be in control of
your own economic life and he justifies
all this with just pure idiotic envious
class warfare so he tweeted out again
today this is his j it's justice deck he
is just bernie sanders now quote folks i
don't want to punish anyone's success
but those at the top have been getting a
free ride for far too long we're going
to change that
it's just pure envy
it's pure class warfare politics now
none of this applies to joe biden
himself
according to a report in the new york
post quote republicans say a new
nonpartisan report indicates president
joe biden improperly avoided paying
medicare taxes before he took office
raising eyebrows and the possibility he
now owes the irs as much as a half
million dollars in back taxes
biden is leading a democratic push for a
3.5 trillion dollar bill to subsidize
child care education and health care by
targeting tax avoidance but a house ways
and means committee drafted the bill
would end an accounting trick apparently
exploited by biden and boost irs funding
for audits
according to jim banks who is the
chairman of the conservative republican
study committee from indiana joe biden
wants to raise taxes by 2.1 trillion
dollars while claiming the rich need to
pay their fair share but in 2017
multi-millionaire joe biden skirted his
payroll taxes the very taxes that fund
medicare and obamacare according to the
criteria provided by the congressional
research to my office he owes the irs
and the american people hundreds of
thousands of dollars in back taxes
every american should know about joe
biden's tax hypocrisy by the way it
doesn't just apply to joe biden it also
applies to hunter
i remember hunter biden is only rich
because daddy is hunter is is joe that's
that's the only reason anyone has ever
heard of hunter biden who's a derelict
and a terrible person and
i know a wayward child we're supposed to
treat him like a wayward child even
though he is like 15 years 16 years
older than i am we're supposed to treat
him like he's a wayward child he's well
into his 50s at this point okay but
apparently hunter biden when he's not
trying to sell his finger paintings for
millions of dollars
in a pretty obvious bribery operation
when he's not doing that apparently
according to business insider
he's attempting to leverage his daddy's
job in order to make money and this goes
all the way back to when his daddy was
vp according to business insider two
previously unpublished emails sent by
business contacts of hunter biden
indicate the president's son requested
an annual retainer of two million bucks
to help recover billions in libyan
assets frozen by the obama
administration the emails obtained by
insider during reporting on an unrelated
matter are not connected to the
controversial emails from hunter biden's
laptop while it appears the new from the
new emails that the libya deal was never
consummated the document offers a window
into the mechanics of beltway influence
peddling and the stock that was put in
biden's political connections
particularly his relationship with his
daddy who's vp at the time
the first email dated january 28th 2015
was sent from
from sam joarie a democratic donor with
businesses in the persian gulf who was
helped spearheading a libya project it
was addressed to sheikh muhammad
al-rahmani another obama campaign's
owner involved in the proposal in the
email jahaori is frank about what biden
would bring to the table and what he
says biden wanted in return quote per
phone conversation i met with number two
son he wants two million bucks per year
retainer plus success fees he wants to
hire his own people it can be a close
circle of people for confidentiality his
dad is deciding to run or not his
positives are he is chairman of the un
world food program son of number two who
has libyaphile access to state treasury
business partners secretary of state
john f kerry son and since he travels
with dad he's connected everywhere in
europe and asia
he has said he has access to the highest
levels in prc and can help there as well
his negatives
are that he is alcoholic drug addict
kicked out of the us army for cocaine
chasing low class hookers constantly
needs money liquidity problems and many
more headaches
we should meet in g-strad or london to
decide next steps
so um
i mean that's that's a pretty
accurate summing up of everything
related to uh to
hunter biden but again the rule is you
can be rich and you can influence pedal
and you can be corrupt as all hell as
long as you proclaim that you are for
the socialist ideal of complete
redistribution of income
and that's the whole shtick because the
more the democrats claim that they are
for redistribution of income the more
they hope to change the nature of how
american government is done which brings
us to the budget we'll get to that in
just one second first let's talk about a
simple fact you don't want to go to the
auto parts store who wants to go to the
auto parts store you stand in line
forever finally get to the front of the
line when you do they finally ask you a
bunch of questions about your car you
answer them then like we don't have the
part we're ordering it online
and you're like well i could have just
ordered it online myself and you know
cut out the middleman they're like yes
but then you wouldn't get this
incredible service okay well you don't
want the incredible service you want
rockauto.com they always offer the
lowest prices possible rather than
changing prices based on what the market
will bear like airlines do why spend up
to twice as much for the same parts
furthermore prices at rockauto.com are
always the same for professionals and
do-it-yourselfers their family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years go to rockauto.com to shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers the catalog is unique and
remarkably easy to navigate you can
quickly see all the parts available for
your vehicle choose the brands
specifications and prices you prefer
head on over to rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available for your car
or truck and write shapiro in their how
did you hear about usbox so they know
that we sent you no reason go to the
auto parts store anymore instead just do
everything online at rockauto.com and
make sure that you mention that you
heard about rockauto.com on the ben
shapiro show okay so meanwhile the white
house is still struggling to iron out
its budget differences according to
politico.com today democratic leaders
efforts to infuse momentum into
turbulent negotiations over president
joe biden's social spending plans are
falling flat so far with key players on
capitol hill
as congress hurtles toward a crucial
wheat that could make or break biden's
agenda centrist and progressives remains
largely unmoved from their entrenched
positions
that leaves speaker nancy pelosi days
away from a vote on a 550 billion senate
pass infrastructure bill without a clear
path to passage
so you'll remember that there is this
bipartisan infrastructure bill the the
kind of bare bones infrastructure bill
passed by the senate is 550 billion
dollars moderates her demanding that she
hold the vote because she promised she
was going to do that progressives are
calling for delay and they're vowing to
tank the legislation as long as they
don't get their giant social spending
bill the 3.5 trillion dollar spending
bill
representative lou korea democrat of
california says you're witnessing
democracy in full bloom everyone wants
to be heard and acknowledged nancy's a
magician
well we're going to find out pelosi and
her team hope that projecting progress
in the talks both with a framework of
financing mechanisms announced thursday
and plans for the house budget committee
to mark up the still unfinished package
this weekend will satisfy progressives
enough to back off their threats pelosi
says we'll take it one day at a time i'm
confident that we will pass both bills
but of course
there's no guarantee that in the senate
the giant 3.5 trillion dollar bill is
going to pass if infrastructure does
pass right now the progressives are
saying we will hold up infrastructure to
get our 3.5 trillion dollar bill and the
moderates are saying pass our
infrastructure
and we're still not going to vote for
your 3.5 trillion bill
so that is an impasse senator manchin
says we don't have any idea what they're
talking about
it sounds good if they're all working
towards something to present to us after
all the conversations yesterday i
haven't seen it
an aide to senator kristen cinema of
arizona she said unclear what chuck
schumer is referring to we've seen
nothing we haven't signed off on
anything
so basically pelosi and schumer are
trying to just ram this through with
happy talk
even with next week's vote looming
democrats path forward is murky at best
has politico with moderates and
progressives locked in a public standoff
over biden's two spending priorities
earlier in the day pelosi and senate
majority leader chuck schumer delivered
a cryptic announcement that they along
with the white house had agreed to a
framework of options to pay for their
social spending ambitions an effort
meant to show forward momentum in these
stalled negotiations house majority
leader steiner hoyer said i think having
a framework will add more confidence to
people as to what we're planning on
doing one of the big problems is people
aren't sure what's going on
house budget committee chair john
yarmuth later announced democrats plans
to mark up the massive package on
saturday admitting it would be more
procedural than substantive because the
bill isn't even done yet
republicans can force symbolic political
votes which would drag the process out
for hours but the budget panel can't
make any binding changes there's still
no budget score cards from the
congressional budget office which are
necessary in order to even pass this
thing through reconciliation
the framework announcement came after
pelosi and schumer emerged from a
meeting with treasury secretary janet
yellen and white house advisor brian
diese and congress's top tax writers
democratic leaders were mum on the
details refusing to say whether a spate
of financing ideas will allow them to
move forward next week with either their
up to 3.5 trillion spending package or
the bipartisan infrastructure plan so it
looks like kind of a mess at the moment
right now again the moderates are saying
we are not spending this much money and
progressives are saying we're not going
to vote for the bipartisan bill
meanwhile bernie sanders is cheering
this framework that still has not been
revealed he says democrats could pay for
this whole thing and absolutely make
sure they follow through on biden's
promise to not increase taxes on
families making under four hundred
thousand dollars a year he says the
truth is it's not hard to come up with
approaches to do away with the tax cap
and to demand the wealthy and large
corporations pay their fair share of
taxes you could do a lot more than 3.5
trillion dollars once again bernie only
cares about spending other people's
money he himself has that third layout
so he's pretty secure so what exactly is
this framework on tax hikes that we are
talking about right now according to the
washington post
the first word of a potential compromise
arrived earlier thursday when pelosi and
schumer said the party had worked at the
white house on a menu of options but the
reality is a little bit more complicated
reflecting instead the talks continue on
some of the thorny issues in some areas
democrats have already agreed they want
to raise the top tax rate to almost 40
percent from 37 percent but on corporate
tax increases lawmakers want to raise
rates but don't see eye to eye on the
amount and of course they want to
radically increase the capital gains tax
which is uh something that joe biden is
pushing really hard and then is lying
about even by thursday afternoon
democrats in the house and senate said
we really have not seen any details here
you just keep saying things and you're
not actually showing us anything
so this has forced joe biden to just lie
about stuff okay so we'll get to joe
biden's latest lie with regard to taxes
in just one second first
let us talk about a simple fact if you
need an education you need to go to a
college that is going to actually mirror
your values right that is going to share
things that are important eternal values
that matter grand canyon university is
one university that does this the ben
shapiro show is proud to be supported by
gcu an affordable christian university
one of the largest fastest growing
universities in the country located in
sunny phoenix arizona gcu is ranked top
20 for best college campuses in america
and offers over 275 engaging academic
programs with over 240 online gcu
integrates the free market system with a
welcoming christian worldview
perspective into its academic programs
so you can put your faith into action
and help transform communities in 2020
gcu students received over 290 million
dollars in scholarships with many
attending gcu for less than the cost of
a state university you can find your
purpose at gcu it is private christian
affordable visit gcu slash my offer and
see what scholarships you qualify for
i've visited gcu it is just a gorgeous
campus the students are wonderful many
of the faculty members are just terrific
go check them out right now
gcu.edu slash my offer see what
scholarships you qualify for alrighty so
what exactly is joe biden's plan here
his plan is to just lie so biden and the
democrats have now put out a report
suggesting that the wealthiest 400
families in the united states are paying
an average income tax rate of just 8.2
percent this is according to a new
analysis from the biden administration
well um there's only one problem with
that which is just it's not true
like it's not true at all how do they
come to that 8.2 number well they lie
the analysis estimated billionaires paid
8.2 of their income 8.2 of their income
between 2010 and 2018 including on forms
of income that go largely on taxed
so in other words they are saying that
billionaires paid 8.2 percent of their
income they're defining income as stocks
as bonds as capital gains
now as anyone who knows anything knows
capital gains are not in fact income
by this metric you can pretty much skew
any stat ever
right you can say that
bob down the street who's paid no
capital gains on the incremental
increase of the value of his home he is
paying a far lower income tax rate than
you thought he was paying
the analysis by economists from the omb
and the white house council of economic
advisors drew from publicly available
data and said the disparity is driven
largely by how the tax code treats
income generated from wealth such as
income from stocks whose worth increases
over time rather than wages which are
immediately taxed
yes that's correct because we do tax
income from wealth and investment
differently than we tax income from
wages why because wages become wealth
you already paid tax on that so we're
already double taxing you
right you got paid by your company you
then took your money and you put it in
your 401k or you went out and you got an
e-trade portfolio and you bought a bunch
of stock
now nancy pelosi and biden and schumer
they're saying well you haven't really
been taxed enough on that have you it's
like well wait a second i i already paid
tax on that
i haven't even sold my stock yet what
are you talking about
if i never sell my stock by the way i
have not realized the gain
or the loss of course you shouldn't be
taxed the same way on income that you
are on investment
now one thing that joe biden is
attempting to cash in on is the fact
that most people in the united states
are wage earners as opposed to people
who are entrepreneurs or investors but
if you remove the incentive for
entrepreneurs to be entrepreneurs and
investors to invest you'll get less
investment and less entrepreneurialism
and more wage base
there's more security in not taking the
risk than there isn't taking the risk
nobody ever thinks about the
sort of
unforeseen economic consequences of this
sort of stupidity okay so let's talk
about this for a second why we tax these
two forms of income differently
the reason we tax capital gains
differently
from how we tax for example
employment income
is because employment income is very
secure you're taking no risk you get
paid a wage the people who work at my
company know that the check is coming
every two weeks right they know the
check is coming
they've taken no risk because they're
walking into work and they are doing
their job and they are getting paid
on the other end of the spectrum those
of us who are owners of the daily wire
have taken a significant amount of risk
we put our own money in for example or
we took lower salaries in order to start
the company
or we took out mortgages on our homes or
we went and we got somebody else to take
the risk by putting money in but then we
took on the burden of having to pay
those people back over the course of
time none of my employees have to pay
back our investors over the course of
time they're employees so of course
it's amazing people will talk about the
excess profits to be earned for example
from in from investment and innovation
and entrepreneurialism
no one ever talks about the excess
losses
okay most people who take risks fail a
huge majority of people who start in the
restaurant business end up not in the
restaurant business their restaurants go
under
nobody ever talks about the fact that
when you talk about the average profit
of investors
the average profit those are the people
who stay the investors in a business
or the entrepreneurs right oh the the
look at look at the rate of return for
entrepreneurs who succeed you never talk
about the people who go bankrupt
okay we we try to incentivize risk
taking because if it were not for the
risk takers if we're not for the
entrepreneurs if it were not for the
people who invest their money it weren't
for you investing your money in the
stock market right and providing capital
so that businesses can use that to hire
people no one gets hired
employees do not exist without employers
employers do not exist without
risk-taking and investment
and innovation and if you cut
all of the benefits of innovation and
investment you may as well turn
everybody into a wage earner the problem
is then there's no one left to pay the
wages
this is why we tax these two forms of
income differently
so biden wants to conflate the two
he says how is it possible for
millionaires and billionaires that can
pay a lower rate of tax than teachers
firefighters or law enforcement officers
again teachers firefighters and law
enforcement officers are wage earners
this is not any sort of degradation of
what wage earners do they do
unbelievably important work
they also are not the people who own the
company and take the risk of having to
forfeit their house if something goes
wrong on the job
the worst that happens to somebody who's
a wager i've been a wager in my career
also right i've worked for companies
where i was not an owner in the company
and the risk that i took is that the
company went under but that risk didn't
attach to me it was just i would have to
go find another job or that i screw up
at my job
but if i've leveraged my entire life in
order to start a business
that's a bit more of a gamble is it not
so biden is hoping that because so many
people are employees as opposed to
employers then we can have the employee
base tax the employers
and it was often said in the 18th
century 19th century by political
philosophers at the moment that you
could essentially have people
tax other people to pay for their
benefits
then the entire system would collapse
that's what biden is betting on the more
he makes people dependent
and then
that dependency is paid for by people
who are not those people
the more you can get people to vote for
that kind of stuff
and it's all well and good until the
entire system collapses
it's all well and good until there is no
one left to do the innovation
the biden administration says they want
the wealthiest americans to quote pay
their fair share
their proposal includes raising the
income tax bracket for the wealthiest
americans back up to almost 40 percent
from 37 percent by the way the united
states has one of those progressive
income tax rates in america in the world
right the rich pay way more taxes than
people at the bottom of the spectrum the
bottom 50 percent of incomers in the
united states essentially pay zero
income tax
the top ten percent of income earners in
the united states pay virtually all of
the income tax in the united states the
top one percent pays something like 40
of all of the income tax in the united
states
so democrats agree that we'll raise the
taxable income
but they also want to include capital
gains for households making more than a
million bucks each year at the same tax
rate 39.6 instead of 20
doubling the tax rate on capital gains
however among democrats there's still
some disagreement in a bill unveiled
last week house democrats proposed
raising the top capital gains rates from
20 to 25 which is a lot less than biden
wanted instead they wanted a three
percent surtax on individuals making
more than five million dollars it didn't
address wealth past from generation to
generation democrats want to tax you for
passing on your wealth to your children
which is one of the reasons you care
about earning additional wealth
you think that if i didn't care about
passing on wealth to my kids i would
continue working as hard as i do i want
to pass on well to my kids i want to
give charity i want to invest in my my
employees i want to invest in our
business and grow it i think it's
important
remove all the incentives and hell i
mean if you're maxing out what i can
give to my kids i may as well take them
on vacations and spend all the money now
before i die
if biden has vowed not to raise taxes on
those making less than 400 thousand
dollars a year he's lying about that too
he's already raising all sorts of
quote-unquote sin taxes
okay all of this comes as the white
house is gambling with a government
shutdown
they are so committed to the idea that
they can spend us into a new way of life
that they are preparing for a government
shutdown because let's face this the
government shutdown is entirely
avoidable
all the democrats have to do is not vote
on a 3.5 trillion dollar package at the
same time that they raise the debt
ceiling that's all
according to the washington post the
white house budget office notified
federal agencies on thursday to begin
preparations for the first shutdown of
the us government since covid
administration officials stress the
request is in line with traditional
procedures seven days ahead of a
shutdown and not a comment on the
likelihood of a congressional deal both
democrats and republicans have made
clear they will fund the government
before the funding expires on september
30th but time is running out lawmakers
are aiming to resolve an enormous set of
tasks in a matter of weeks house
democrats earlier this week approved a
measure to fund the government suspend
the debt ceiling and approve emergency
aid such as disaster relief
but that plan is expected to die in the
senate because gop is not going to
support democratic attempts to lift the
debt ceiling so long as the democrats
immediately plan to ram through a 3.5
trillion dollar budget plan
with the first of two major deadlines
looming next week democrats publicly
maintain current course they have
pledged to put the house back bill
before the senate that would fund the
government into december and allow the
country to borrow freely throughout most
of 2022. senate majority leader schumer
said quote every single member of this
chamber is going to go on record as to
whether they support keeping the
government open and averting a default
or support shutting us down and
careening our country toward a first
ever default
well i mean
the democrats could avert the default by
not pledging to spend more money than
god has ever seen
privately democrats are beginning to
acknowledge they're unlikely to prevail
in the face of a gop blockade democrats
have to start have started discussing
the mechanics of how to sidestep
republicans as soon as next week
we're looking at all the options but a
government shutdown is not acceptable
says senator chris van hollen of
maryland
many government functions are financed
through spending bills that must be
approved by congress including things
from the military to education programs
before one fiscal year ends and the next
begins alternatively lawmakers can pass
short-term measures that sustain
existing funding to buy themselves time
absent those actions the money runs out
resulting in a full or partial shutdown
now missing the deadline doesn't bring
all government operations to immediate
halt every time there's a bit of a
government shutdown and this has
happened several times in the last 10
years everybody acts as the world is
going to end and nothing happens
like really nothing happens in fact so
little happens that barack obama has to
shut down national parks to pretend that
anybody cares it's a shutdown like open
air world war ii memorials so that he
can cuddle world war ii veterans into
being upset
many of the people who are government
employees they just continue working
because they are essential employees
the implications for a shutdown during a
public health crisis could be very
different supposedly according to the
washington post
democrats are struggling to advance
multiple spending measures all at once
they don't have to do this they are
laboring to advance 4 trillion bucks in
economic initiatives backed by biden
the proposal is tied to a second roughly
3.5 trillion bill to expand medicare
boost education and child care programs
combat climate change
in a sign of a new scramble to avoid a
shutdown the senate's two top
appropriators chairman pat leahy of
vermont democrat and top republican
richard shelby of alabama huddled
thursday to discuss potentially
including a short-term agreement to keep
the government funded that could be done
without an increase in the debt ceiling
right now however the democrats seem to
want to play chicken well good luck
playing chicken well the reason that we
are playing chicken in the first place
is because you want to spend money on
programs that are
relatively unpopular nobody's interested
in blowing out the debt this way
and by the way i will note here that it
is it is really
impressive how many people on the left
have used china as a model of how we
should grow in the future meanwhile
ignoring the fact that china
basically is destroying its own economy
through debt
china's had multiple debt crises over
the past five years alone
and now they're in the middle of another
debt crisis
according to the wall street journal
the current 2021 everground crisis
puts the chinese in a very bad situation
because the uh because the chinese have
invested too heavily in housing for too
long through housing subsidies so
they're experiencing their own 2008 over
there it turns out the debt led growth
is generally a prescription for failure
if you never reign in the spending
okay in just one second we'll get to the
latest with regard to
funding priorities because it turns out
that aoc is crying
again we'll get to that in a second
first let us talk about a thing that is
this is such a cool device it really is
cool so my wife tends to get really
really carsick and one thing over time
that we've tried is relief band it's an
fda cleared anti-nausea wristband it has
been clinically proven to quickly
relieve and effectively prevent nausea
and vomiting associated with motion
sickness anxiety migraines hangovers
morning sickness chemo and so much more
the product is 100 drug-free it's
non-drowsy it provides all-natural
relief with zero side effects for as
long as necessary
the technology was originally developed
over 20 years ago in hospitals to
relieve nausea from patients but now
through relief band it's available to
the masses it's so cool okay basically
it is a wristband that stimulates a
nerve in your wrist and that travels to
the part of the brain that controls
nausea and then it blocks that signal
that the brain is sending to the stomach
telling you that you're sick
it is the only over-the-counter wearable
device that has been used in hospitals
and oncology clinics to treat nausea and
vomiting again it works for my wife my
sister also tends to get car sick i got
her a relief band as well right now
relief band has an exclusive offer just
for ben shapiro listeners head on over
to reliefband.com use promo code shapiro
you will receive 20 off plus free
shipping and a no questions asked 30 day
money back guarantee head on over to
reliefband.com
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d dot com use our
promo code shapiro for 20 off plus free
shipping go check them out right now
alrighty we'll get to more of this in
just one second first you deserve to
wake up to the facts that's why we
started our newest podcast morning wire
it's been topping the apple and spotify
charts since its recent release it is
the only daily news podcast that values
your time and the truth and while we are
working overtime to bring you the news
you need to know we need your help to
keep the facts trending toward number
one so subscribe and start listening now
on morning wire at apple spotify
wherever you listen to podcasts leave a
five star review if you like what you
hear you're listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
all righty meanwhile uh just a reminder
that the squad is garbage just there
it's filled with terrible people so
over the past 48 hours there was an
attempt by the democrats to
push republicans to basically
push forward spending bills by including
in spending bills things like funding
for iron dome which is the israeli
defense system and the squad voted it
down like members of the squad who were
in favor of increasing the spending
republicans voted against it because
they didn't want to increase the
spending period democrats were in favor
of increasing the spending they just
didn't like israel at least members of
the squad
so rashida talib was just the
d hamas in the like she's just a
terrorist representative apparently in
the american congress because that's all
she does just stand for hamas so she
went out there and she said she was very
upset that now the democrats brought up
correctly a separate funding bill for
one billion dollars for iron dome which
is a purely defensive technology and
rashida talib said she didn't want any
funding for war crimes
i will not support an effort to enable
and support war crimes human rights
abuses and violence we cannot be talking
only about israelis need for safety at a
time when palestinians are living under
a violent apartheid system and are dying
from what human rights watch has said
are war crimes
okay speaker of the house nancy pelosi
was like um the hell are you talking
about iron dome is a purely defensive
system designed to safeguard all
civilians living in israel the system
was co-developed by the united states
and israel and has saved thousands of
lives so whatever subsidy we're paying
to israel we're getting back in terms of
the technology
um and pretty much everybody voted for
it right everybody
the final vote on this thing had i think
nine people who did not vote for it
uh ted deutsch the representative from
palm beach he uh he came out he's a
democrat and finally i'm refuted talib
is the anti-semite chief he's only two
years late on this
i cannot allow one of my colleagues to
stand on the floor of the house of
representatives
and label the jewish democratic state of
israel in apartheid state i reject it
let's be clear
it's consistent with those who advocate
for the dismantling of the one jewish
state in the world
and when there is no place on the map
for one jewish state
that's anti-semitism yes it most
certainly is and the anti-semites
include representatives rashida talib
ilhan omar no shock there i mean they're
just openly allied at this point with
hamas ayanna presley the ringo starr of
the squad cory bush the blm
congresswoman from missouri that's also
not a shock because the blm organization
is openly anti-semitic andre carson
marie newman jesus garcia and raul
grivalva and uh one republican
representative thomas massey who voted
against because he votes against pretty
much every funding bill and that is that
is why massey voted against it now
because he's anti-israel just because he
doesn't like pretty much any funding
aoc
is the one we should focus on here so
originally the vote came around and aoc
voted against funding iron dome
then aoc backed off of it because as
always she is just cosplaying the
revolution that is all she wants to be
seen as radical but then when it comes
right down to it she just wants power
and money that's all she wants aoc she
wants to run for senate in new york
you ain't getting far running for the
senate in new york being overtly
anti-semitic the way they do hannah
marner shooted to libar alejandro martin
get away with it because she's from a
district in minnesota
that is extraordinarily
far left and radical against israel
and the same is true for rashida talib
that is not true for a it may be true in
her district it is certainly not true
statewide so whatever hope she has for
statewide office rests on her abstaining
so she actually abstained from this
but you know she she did have to cry
some crocodile tears so no tears for the
people
who are attempting to cross the border
down in in del rio texas no tears about
that but she broke out the the sobbing
again after switching her vote so she
knew where the cameras were because she
always knows where the cameras are i
mean she's like a moth to a flame when
it comes to cameras aoc made her way
down while somebody else was speaking
and then
pretty overtly started
dabbing at her eyes because she was so
sad that she had abstained from this
from this particular bill so terrible
that israel has defensive technology to
prevent its citizens from being
slaughtered on mass by a terrorist group
firing rockets indiscriminately into
civilian areas
destiny by mr lawson florida you can see
her approach
when she walks up to fellow congress
person and she's she's so sad she's
upset
and she removes her glasses she knows
exactly where the camera is this whole
time right she removes her glasses and
she starts dabbing at her eyes
ah
oh the sadness oh
the pain
ah
she is just terrible so the squad
proving itself once again i'm so glad
the future of the democratic party rests
with these jokers all right we're going
to finish the week with a piece of good
news here
so i know that the democrats would love
to have you continue to panic about
covet for the rest of time and in fact
you have the education secretary who
just came out and said we should
actually mandate covet 19 vaccines in
schools this is miguel cardona he said
not only do i support it i'm encouraging
states to come with a plan to make sure
it happens i would like governors who
hold those decisions to make decisions
now that vaccines are fda approved
there's a reason we're not talking about
measles today it was a required
vaccination we put it behind us i do
believe at this point we need to be
moving forward yes the reason that we
are not talking about measles is because
meals foot measles is a childhood
disease it was not endemic among the
population
the basic notion that if you mandate
vaccinations for small children with
regard to cova that you're going to wipe
out covet is silly there's not a single
scientist who believes this is the case
no one believes we are getting to zero
covet
but now we're talking about mandating
for small children these vaccines which
again is one thing to say for adults who
have a higher risk that they ought to be
thinking about taking the vaccine
because the risks from covet outweigh
the risks from the vaccine but when
you're talking about the risks of
covered to small children the risks are
so unbelievably minute that you're
talking about gradations of risk and
maybe a little bit of long-term testing
might be a little bit better
like we can barely get the cdc and the
fda to agree on who should get booster
shots at this point who are adults
and here you have government actors
suggesting that we are going to mandate
vaccines for children with regard to
covenant 19 again with regard to a
disease that
kids are just not dying from in large
numbers
and in many years there have been more
deaths like half of the past 10 years
there have been more deaths from the flu
than there have been from covet over the
period of covid
and yet you have the democrats
continuing to push this stuff gavin
newsom the uh the once and future
governor of california he says that a
vaccine mandate is still on the table
for kids
we want to continue to be vigilant we
want to continue to lean in we still
have a lot of work to do i worry about a
winter surge and so yes it's now back on
the table uh to get our kids vaccinated
12 to 17. we're not seeing the numbers
we're seeing for other age cohorts the
decision will be made over the course
the next few days we have a lot of
partners with 1050 school districts in
the state of california the largest
school system in the united states but
it is true our health director said it
today that this is on the table it's
being debated uh and over the next few
days uh we will come out i'm sorry this
is this is ridiculous this is ridiculous
okay but i told you i'd end with some
good news here's the good news according
to the latest uk data you know other
countries actually have data we don't
bother to do data in the united states
we just have our fda and cdc pretty much
just pull out of their ass and they
don't have any rationale for it okay
here's the data from the uk you ready
long coveted symptoms are higher in the
control group than in the covid positive
group for young children at 12 to 16
weeks post-infection
so you're more likely to have
long-covered symptoms in a control group
than in the covet-positive group for
kids post-infection not only that
the woman who created the oxford vaccine
now says the covet is unlikely to mutate
into a much deadlier deadlier variant
and will eventually just cause something
that looks like the common cold
so there's your good news is that we are
pretty much at the end of this thing but
uh they're not going to stop the panic
because the panic is how they get things
done alrighty we will be back here next
week make sure over the weekend that you
check out our brand new episode of the
sunday special with brett weinstein and
heather heing they have a brand new book
out about evolutionary biology which is
verboten in leftist circles you're
definitely going to want to read the
book and you're really going to want to
listen to the podcast i think it's
fabulous it's really just a fascinating
conversation and we'll be back here
later today with an additional hour of
content first you can't forget to end
your week by checking out the andrew
clavin show truth shows every friday
he's got an exciting evening planned for
you as always so head on over to
dailywire.com 7 pm eastern 6 pm central
tune in i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pavo
widdowski associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciovitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica kranz the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin